stay on the river is dry
this fountain no longer flows
the ground is parched
this village like much of france is in
the grip of the country's worst ever
drought
i've lived here for 17 years and never
seen this says the chief of police
philippe granesh
since april not a drop of water it's sad
philippe is taking us to see the
emergency supplies many here now rely on
one of the village's main water sources
has dried up
so eight times a day this truck pumps
water into the systems so the taps don't
run completely dry
people are limited to 200 liters a day
philippe's daily police patrol now
includes looking out for water thieves
break the rules and it's a 1 500 euro
fine
this shows you just how bad things have
got this river has been dry since the
winter when it should have been
overflowing and it's a picture being
repeated across two-thirds of france
which are currently at a drought crisis
level
four heat waves have triggered weeks of
wildfires and in places reduced the
mighty lua to a stream
last week a hundred places were without
tap water
olives are suffering
the ground around them so dry it
crunches
so far restaurants water isn't being
restricted here but if the drought gets
worse everyone's supply may need to be
controlled a disaster says patrick
images
but there is no respite nothing to
quench this arid land
another week of high temperatures means
much of france will continue to bake
siobhan robbins sky news seoul southeast
france